they're already in America having passed
the middle of the Rio Grande the river
between the U.S and Mexico these migrant
families have waded into U.S territory
only to find a Thicket of sharp wires
blocking them from ascending the
riverbank
they decide it won't stop them
[Music]
the look of Terror on this girl's face
is matched by the determined detection
on her father's
this woman struggles for words this girl
from Honduras got nicked by the razors
her father quickly comes to her Aid
this is painful but we had to find
relief we feed for our lives in Honduras
we come to humbly ask for Asylum
sometimes U.S border Patrol agents take
pity and help
a tearful two-year-old crosses the wires
in the arms of an agent his mother is
grateful
he just doesn't like being held by
anyone else but her she says there's a
brief respite and the people who were
just trapped behind this razor wire have
all been rescued by U.S border Patrol
but this opening still exists and so we
have a rare opportunity to peek behind
the razor wire to see just what these
circumstances are the hill is steep and
slippery The Sun Burns hot people
somehow pass the night here before their
rescue but just as quickly as border
patrol agents who report to Washington
open the fence to allow people through
soldiers who report to the state of
Texas quickly close the fence back up
excuse me sir
excuse me I'm confused because we just
saw border patrol cutting through this
wire why are you guys putting back more
no comment the governor of Texas says
such deterrents are needed because the
bide Administration is failing to secure
the border the chief of U.S border
Patrol defended his agency's actions
Tuesday to ask my men and women
to sit there and watch them succumb to
the environment to ask them to watch
them get Swept Away by the river to ask
them to watch women and children drown
is not something I or anybody else would
ever do
these migrants are on their way to find
Border Patrol agents to turn themselves
in America and to make Asylum claims
these others had the poor luck of
meeting State Police first and so faced
a different reception handcuffs and a
forced March
behind them still more people are
crossing the river they take one
obstacle at a time celebrating each step
toward their goal
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Eagle Pass
Texas
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera